and now you know uh with this viral clip
from this show dan bungino was posting
it we had derek arvion who mentioned
that
you know trump declassified crossfire
hurricane he probably brought copies of
the documents with him they went to get
it back because they don't want it
exposed or something like that and it
was the team that did it that went to
his house to take it this all makes
sense
they come to his house and say you
better lock this up like it better he
does then then the fbi comes back and
breaks the lock different group of fbi
agents it sounds like we're at the point
where there's different factions in the
fbi that are fighting each other
a poll just came out
that majority of the people in this
country feel
that an element of the fbi is acting as
joe biden's personal gestapo
you said that was a poll what's the poll
was it let me
we have it um
examiner says majority see fbi as
biden's personal gestapo after trump
raped this is the examiner this is not
some you know this is crazy rasmussen
survey 53 of likely voters agree there's
a group of politicized thugs the top of
the fbi that are using the fbi's joe
biden's personal gestapo
i think it's a civil war i saw them as
gestapo when they raided veritas right
like that's insane
this is this is the
the breakdown this is the culture we're
reaching the highest levels of
government that i was told would never
happen
so when you hear like like i mentioned
when you hear
that the fbi told trump's people to
secure these documents with a padlock
and they do and then a few months later
come in and smash the padlock it makes
no sense unless you point out unless the
reality is it was a different group of
fbi agents who did it
and i had someone reach out to me
claiming to be a retired agent who said
you're exactly right there there may be
there is leadership there is leadership
at the top but different you know uh
managers or or you know uh supervisors
and different fields in different
interests
exactly are going to be doing things
against each other's interests yeah i
think uh well i was actually looking
into this because you know a lot of
people started talking about defunding
the fbi and i was like i was actually
thinking about what could a president do
with just an executive order right
abolish it
they could do a lot uh the fbi doesn't
have like an explicit deal much in the
way of explicit delegated authority from
congress it actually is delegated to the
attorney general who then has like the
right to appoint officials but the fbi
is sort of like implicitly
it's not actually like mandated by
congress in the same way that other law
enforcement agencies are and so
theoretically like a president and an
attorney general could essentially just
make it an executive order that's like
the fbi only does the things that is
very specifically mandated to do by
congress like track serial killers and
everything else
is that
congress there's like certain certain
specific statutes that mandate things
that the fbi should handle but they're
like narrow but does the does congress
um prescribe through statutory law the
maintenance of the fbi no
i i read or it might it might fund it
but that's that's different from saying
so that basically you'd be you you could
basically strip the fbi of authority
even if you didn't strip it of funding
via
there's a meme that's going around that
that trump could sign an executive order
disbanding it outright because it's got
no congressional authority into its
existence that it was created by
executive order or something like that
yeah i think i mean
i'm not i don't know that's sure but i
just i'm i'm pretty confident though
about the ability of the president to
just kind of decide to you know say okay
guess guess what fbi like on day one
you're not doing counterintelligence
anymore right like done you don't have
you don't have any access to it i'm
allocating that authority to other
intelligence agencies oh wow it was
linked to prohibition that's where it
started huh that sounds right there's
there's a lot of i mean i think
prohibition is one of the big things
bank robberies when bank robberies were
a big deal that was like a big uh
trigger for i think it was that was like
more like when the fbi really got a lot
of its expansion because one of the one
of the problems that um there was a it
was a huge problem in the midwest where
you have all these states that are
pretty small and and like can't think
about something like kansas city where
it's across the border in kansas and
missouri so you'd have bank robbers
constantly robbing a bank in kansas and
then crossing the border of missouri and
not getting prosecuted right roosevelt
did start kind of starting an early form
of the fbi after uh
mckinley was assassinated it's
interesting how it evolved into
existence it wasn't it wasn't outright
created so when you look at the history
of the fbi it talks about the um the
national bureau of criminal
identification which eventually evolves
into the bureau of investigation which
eventually evolves into the federal
bureau of investigation
it's interesting and there was this is
interesting it says
there were fears the new agency would
serve as secret police as a secret
police department again at roosevelt's
urging bonaparte moved to organize a
formal bureau of investigation which
would then have its own staff of special
agents yeah this was yeah this was teddy
roosevelt i think i'm literally just
started a book about this because i was
interested uh
teddy roosevelt was you know annoyed
with essentially you know environmental
issues actually oddly enough progressive
yeah conservative pretty pretty
progressive like he didn't like uh you
know some big corporate interests
screwing up the environment certain
states and you know getting away with it
davis national parks yeah
this is crazy it was it was created by
the attorney general he just one day
brought in people and said
report to uh the chief examiner chief
examiner as investigators and then they
gave a name to the group the bureau of
investigation and then 1935 they renamed
it the federal bureau of investigation
that's it yeah in which case the
executive branch could just literally be
like you're gone yeah or just reroute it
like basically i mean there might be
other laws or other statutes that are
like funding the fbi or essentially you
know the civil service rules that
protect the people there okay that's all
fine but you could you could just strip
it of authority and tell them all to go
play bridge like you know not go kidnap
a governor yeah right or yeah yeah all
that you can stop doing that my animal
brain my lizard brain has a hard time
with the idea of of it erasing the fbi
because i've it's been with me my whole
life so i'm like wouldn't that cause
chaos if we don't have enough i mean you
need to replace certain of its functions
for sure right like you don't want to i
mean this is not like get rid of having
a sort of federal police force there are
things you need a federal police force
or when it comes to enforcing federal
law yes okay but i mean one thing i
joked about was you just create a a new
federal justice bureau you know think
about what the acronym is fjb fjd
right agreed
just for that reason we do it right
there's a new federal justice startup
duplicates the functions of the fbi but
you just make all the current fbi
officials like reapply for their jobs
right that would be you know there's a
lot of like clever things you could do
given the fact that they don't
the whole the institution doesn't have
that much statutory protection how
amazing would it be if donald trump gets
reelected
and then immediately following his
inauguration and swearing in he doesn't
address where he's like my fellow
americans you may remember a few years
ago when the fbi
came into my home
it was terrible terrible everyone says
it was one of the most terrible things i
am signing a negative order there is no
more fbi i just it would be hilarious
only one term he can't get re-elected
he's not going to care he's like do
something i don't know i understand the
need for it though i do i get it but
this has got to go this is oh yeah
it needs to be like radical oh my
goodness like it's just a corrupt right
now the institution itself is really
corrupt
what president started the cia um but
which everyone did
after jfk was assassinated i believe
that president wrote a letter like an
op-ed saying we got to disband the cia
because he was convinced
he was just he was he was convinced like
they had something to do with it harry
truman 1940. it was true
yeah truman said he created it after jfk
was assassinated then he wrote a letter
saying we got to disband the cia and
then the head of the cia went and
visited truman and said you got to not
say that and he was like nah i'm sorry
hold on so like truman created it
yup and then after jfk died he wrote a
letter saying an op-ed or something
saying like i think they got too much
power wow that's not what i intended
yeah crazy interesting i don't know
about like i think the cia certainly
does have you know its fingers and some
bad stuff like a lot of bad stuff
actually but domestically it's like
sounds like it's mostly the fbi yeah
yeah well the other thing other unique
thing you could do is you know we
are kind of unique among western
countries and that we have both the same
institution handles both like federal
policing and counterintelligence and
those are not norm those are not
necessarily like combined functions
right one is like detecting spies and
like thwarting foreign intelligence
efforts and the other is like just
federal police work right
you know investigating crimes and
helping the doj prosecutor if if donald
trump is going to get rid of the the fbi
i just he's got to preserve the x-files
and make sure that they're the one thing
is the x-files real though like it's an
action it was an actual like the actual
show was based off of like the filing
they would do for things they couldn't
explain not like any agents actually
like aliens are among us but they're
like hey we don't know how this happened
this is crazy
if if people out there have watched the
latest episode of tales from the
inverted world they would have seen the
letter i wrote to president carter
me demanding transparency of uh he you
know when he was on the campaign trail
he promised to release all ufo documents
because carter saw ufo in georgia
and then he talked about it extensively
on the campaign trail promising this and
the second he got into office like most
politicians do he backpedaled and didn't
release anything because of national
security quote unquote
um but i'm still trying to hit him up oh
yeah
yeah i think they were drone programs a
lot of what people were told were alien
or just
whether or not they have fusion packs on
board i wonder and that's what i tell
them actually it could be
extraterrestrials it could be our
military it could be it is it is totally
fictional but i i remember reading just
want to clarify that i remember reading
something that it was like the idea of
the show came from something that was
really within the fbi yeah air force is
the air force yeah i just said well i
just saw an article was there a
real-life version of the x-files the
answer is yes and it was part of the air
force uh alex hollings let me see if i
can find the exact um
who says it's false yes
wikipedia oh no it says it's fixed fbi
but that's the thing like it says a
fictional uh case deemed solvable by the
fbi i read somewhere that the show was
inspired by
something that like it's not literally
the x-files but like somebody was
reading about how the fbi couldn't solve
something and they're like oh we should
do a show like that and call it
something well they have certainly done
experiments like the remote viewing
stuff where they'd sit the cops in a
room or just bring people i believe it
was fbi well you know about the men who
stare at goats i haven't seen it but
yeah i know about it well like that is
based on right right yeah the stargate
giving them uh were they drugging them
up
yeah what's the ghost how weird do they
actually stare at goats
weren't they trying to explode them or
something oh i don't know about that i
think they were trying to use
telekinesis to kill goats i'm not sure
i read i read about this
but yeah the u.s people like yo bro we
were talking about some crazy stuff
downstairs like cia masks
like these super high-tech mission
impossible kind of masks they have
the the heart attack gun yep bro the
heart attack gun is real oh yeah
oh it's hilarious you can go and there
was a great channel on youtube i think
they nuked it it was called film
archives and this person would upload
great congressional hearings from the
50s 60s 70s 80s up until now actually
and uh there was one with the heart
attack gun there kind of just passing
around the heart attack gun you're like
oh so you shoot this at someone and give
them a heart attack okay the cia's heart
attack gun yeah no doubt no doubt so
they had that in the 60s or 70s what
frozen shellfish toxin would enter the
target's bloodstream and kill them in
mere minutes but i kind of wonder like
couldn't you just put
like uh
oh my god anything real yeah
that's yeah that's it that's it
so the idea was back then i guess it was
hard to detect the toxin so if you if
someone was shot by the dart they would
die and they'd be like i don't know what
happened these days
i mean there's so much stuff
i was reading about
certain like vitamin mixtures that can
cause cardiac arrest heart attacks and
that when they did your blood test
they would just see like potassium and
sodium and stuff and be like i don't
know but like we've way advanced the
craziness of this thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you